I never considered myself a gamer I was
just a kid that's what you did and it
was really was like the social lubricant
at the time like I wouldn't call you up
and say hey Dave you wanna have a
sleepover talking about girls I did okay
you want played Mario and I'm correct
about girls hey I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me on the Rubin report today is
the author of console wars and the
history of the future
Blake Harris welcome to the Rubin report
thank you for having me on Dave I have
to say that it's nice to be here it's
always nice any place someone wants to
talk about my books they both my life
but I'm a big fan of your show and we'll
get into it I'm sure but this most
recent book is very difficult and listen
your ear amuse was a comfort to me
seriously like I'm taking a lot of
coffee walks and just having a rational
conversation I was like this is what I'm
missing for my life so Wow well thank
you very much I appreciate that I'm
really happy that you're here now first
off today when we're taping this
although this will not air today today
is hashtag National video game day so I
feel it's a very fitting yeah
day to have a video game guy on so I'm
gonna be my video game best self here
today and then listeners and viewers
should know that you have gamer cred
degree room you have a Genesis emulator
and you have your childhood NES so I was
very impressed so yeah I came with a
high opinion but even higher Wow so I've
got yeah so that's a it's a fake
emulator just means fake right like yeah
it's just a fake one it's not my
original Sega Genesis I've got that
thing that is my childhood NES Israel
which wasn't working for years and I
took it apart I watched a youtube video
on how to take it apart and you know use
rubbing alcohol and and apparently
technically you're not supposed to blow
in the cartridges did you know that yeah
but I like I still totally disagree yeah
you know I'm somewhat of an expert on
this and I have you know every other
experts all may know you're not supposed
to blow on it but it works that's like
the people who say you don't restart
your computer we have a problem and then
just somehow works and ApS works they
reject which I guess is a you know a
very populist thing to do the experts I
know that I went to like this vintage
video game store to get a couple of
those old Sega Genesis games and I made
a joke to the guy about blowing in the
games and he freaked out no you're not
supposed to do that you got to use
rubbing
I thought I'm gonna so I've got those
two in there old Sega Genesis old
Nintendo Entertainment System I've got a
ps4 which was given to me by former
Rubin report guests and your friend
video game all-star Colin Moriarty yeah
great guy good friend I loved seeing him
go initially just leaving IGN and
flexing his entrepreneurial muscles and
then starting his own thing yeah he's a
good guy he said good things about you
what made you get the NES and not the
Genesis has done a few recall since I
said you know I'm investing contours
like why did you pick this yeah so well
this is exactly where I wanted to start
so your first book is console wars and
it's basically about the battle between
Sega and Nintendo really like early mid
to early 80s into when would you say
that war sort of sure shifted and then
I'll answer your question okay no yeah
so my first book was console wars it
came out in May 2014 it was
life-changing for me before that book I
was a commodities broker training sugar
coffee and soybeans for Brazilian
clients and then I finally got to retire
from that and do what I love for living
and largely that was because seth rogen
had optioned my book so and and i that
not just because to name-drop seth rogen
is a wonderful opportunity but because
but you know by book and this one as
well and everything i write it was right
right with my grandma in mind like how
can I get her to care about say can
attend them how can I get her to care
about virtual reality and it's the human
story it's you know or always people
that tell me it's like a literary movie
so that's how I sort of write things and
the sort of council wars is this battle
between Sega Nintendo Nintendo
resurrected the game industry with the
NES that you have been 1985 and then
Sega tried to beat them with Master
System and failed miserably and then
between 1990 and 96 Sega
you know took on Nintendo and wouldn't
intended like 95 percent of the market
they surpass them for a while and they
flame down and yeah so it's this
behind-the-scenes story and so I'm
always really curious since since those
are the people the boardroom saying how
can I get a young Dave Rubin yeah by the
system well that's exactly why I wanted
to have you on because it's so first off
your next book which is your new book
the history of the future is gonna get
us
that'll be the second half of this
interview and that will get us sort of
up to speed on what's going on with tech
and sort of gaming and Technology and
virtual reality and all that but the
first half where I wanted to focus on
these things I mean most of my audience
knows I consider myself sort of like a
like a retired video game because those
old systems way I just don't have that
much time anymore so that that's one
thing but those old systems there was a
simplicity to it there you know you
could usually just run one direction you
couldn't even run that way I couldn't
even run backwards you know Mario could
run that way but the more he were in
that way the rest room you had this way
there was a certain simplicity to all of
it that to grow up with it I mean I
remember 1985 I'm nine years old I
remember my buddy John getting nintendo
entertainment system with gyromite and
duck hunter and it had that ridiculous
robot gyromite Rob the robot yeah Rob
the robot and I remember it just blew my
mind I could not believe anything could
be this cool the amount of hours that me
and my friends spent sleepovers playing
in either Mario Brothers or eventually
we shifted mostly to the sports games
bases-loaded and RBI baseball and double
dribble and all those things on us and
and all the games not working and blowin
in the games and you know sometimes
taking apart the controllers to get
everything working and all that are we
roughly you probably a couple years
younger than me maybe six you're 36 so
I'm 43 so I'm a little how do you
remember all that like you know
obviously reflect on that era a lot and
video games I never considered myself a
gamer I was just a kid and that's what
you did and it was really was like the
social lubricant at the time like I
wouldn't call you up and say hey Dave
you wanna have a sleepover talking about
girls they'd be like hey you want
playing Mario and I'm correct about
girls Winkies and like it was just this
thing that you did and I did pretty
poorly I've always been bad at video
games were you not a good gamer no it's
kind of embarrassing cuz there's so few
bad game books which is part of why I
want to write one and gamers are so
disrespected and you know like I did so
embraced by that community and I want
there to be more books but I'm terrible
and I never try to hide that but I think
it's a big part of why I like you you
know if I have an hour and poly gonna be
playing you know ma jam or nine and 93
or something like that instead of the
late
just games because I'm just terrible
damn it's a little too complex from Anna
and I just uh you know simple gamer
hearty right well it was one thing to
only run this way and not run this way
but now you're running this way and you
can run this way and that's where for me
for the tiny brief moments of time I
have I'm like I'd rather just play
contra yeah up up down down left right
left right B a select start and you know
have fun for 10 minutes and then try to
put play a game that's gonna basically
give me a headache
yeah one thing I thought was pretty
interesting is so you know I assume that
the two reasons that we like playing
these games is it's simple and fun which
is like what you look for in a game and
then also the nostalgia factor these are
aimed at on our lives but I've spoken to
college students and high school
students and and it's been so amazing
that they describe you know they play
Mario games the games from the 80s games
in 90s and I said like how come like why
those if you they say oh it's just so
nostalgic but it's not nostalgic to that
knitting crow up it's not writing
they're like but so what is it that it's
reminding them up like their parents
it's interesting I guess it's a
two-prong thing in a certain way where
it's sort of like the the simplicity and
fun part right because it was just two
buttons there was a limited amount of
things you could do I think the games
generally focused maybe a little bit
more on fun where they're now focused on
challenges or something like that and
and and right and much more heavy on
graphics and story where you know you
have to wait a lot every time I put on
that PlayStation 4 it's mostly like I'm
literally sleeping by the time we get to
the next screen
but the nostalgia part is interesting
because I'll now I have a ten-year-old
nephew and I'll play PlayStation with
him or I've even watched him play with
some of his friends and they're playing
like you know NBA 2k 19 or something and
to be of a certain age and to be able to
immerse yourself fully in something
that's really what I think it is that if
you can remember what that feeling is
like for those little brief moments and
there are moments when I'm playing with
him where I can suddenly feel that when
you're completely immersed and I'm not
thinking about politics or in fact that
the world spinning off its axis or you
know whatever else is going on there I
think it's a few of those things but
what enough about me I want to talk
about these these console wars
I remember being in arcades sort of
before that so I never saw Atari was the
system before NES came out that was the
main one there was also there were a
couple others colecovision yeah the
Magnavox Odyssey I mentioned that
because the guy who invented video games
Ralph Baer created that and I got to
spend a lot of time with him before he
passed away and then just a great guy
who should always be mentioned cuz he's
often forgotten and then you know Nolan
Bushnell Atari got a lot of credit and
did great things colecovision television
and then the industry died in 1983
there's this crash of video games they
you know sort of famously highlighted by
the burial of millions of et cartridges
because they actually made more et
cartridges than there were consoles
right and it was terrible right so I
remember that game I remember my friend
Adam had it on atari and it was a
horrible stiff no lead to admit it was
bad because nobody would admit like
fifty bucks you had to love these things
or you pretend you love them so it was a
great game what what were they possibly
thinking of so Atari puts out a game
with more copies than the system itself
this seems like I'm not a great business
man but this doesn't seem like a great
business to me right but but it's almost
like it's just it's the personification
of what always happens you know when you
have a success you can't fail and
there's a hubris and so they said its
licensing it's a popular movie it's a
game you know it's probably made by
people who had lost touch with the
audience it worked like a spy the best
thing you can say about it but but it
was made I think it's six weeks and and
then really that did just like personify
the fact that that there was this over
saturation of games cuz you know for
younger listeners and viewers out there
remember like you know this is before
the Internet we didn't know what we were
getting I remember going to like toys
are baby toys with my parents yeah and
it was like this special time there was
goodbye brother game the first time it
wasn't for a birthday Hanukkah or
whatever and our entire criteria for
choosing the game was just the box
we'd like we'd no idea what the gameplay
was like so people I'm sure that et I
mean it did sell well initially because
people were like oh it's et it's Atari
can't-miss but I definitely missed and
and then the industry essentially died
like you know when Nintendo went out in
1985 and and introduced the SantaCon
which was the you know family computer
in Japan which here was the 8-bit
Nintendo Entertainment System know it's
not an exaggeration to say like I talked
to the guys who would go into where's a
RadioShack and try to sell these things
and and they would not give him the time
of day the the vendors there and buyers
were just like I don't want video games
we lost a lot of money on this so you
know I had those same memories as you
with Nintendo was just you know my eyes
light up playing it again and back then
it was just amazing but but but it
wasn't at the quality was just about
this baggage yeah it's so hard to
believe that at some level because you
know so I'm nine years old in 1985 and
it just took over our world
but after that crash what caused that
two year window from 83 to 85 what was
it that in detent in Tendo was able to
do because it was a huge jump in
graphics it was a huge jump in music but
it wasn't just that it was also the fun
thing like Super Mario 2 like that
defined a generation and actually built
an entire industry basically right I
mean obviously the easiest answer is
good games or better games than what
came before and that's certainly true
you know was a step up in a way that
hasn't really happened before to go from
like Frogger to Super Mario Brothers is
a big jump but as you know I as you
learned going behind the scenes with
both these books it's so much of it is
about the marketing the promotion and
all that and Nintendo just had a really
unique approach to all this you know you
probably finally remember the Nintendo
Power the Nintendo oh yeah like I had
intended I was like a sort of like a
cult in the best sense of the word it
was like you know getting kids involved
in this thing I remember one quote from
menara Arakawa who's the president of
Tendo America him saying that they were
suggesting like you know we need to put
out like five games at the same time
he's like no I want I think it was his
outlet to be out mostly and no other
game really feel like six week because
he wants it everyone playing the same
thing at the same time what did this
communal experience I think that was a
big part of it too there was like a
concerted effort behind it and I do
remember being communal I remember
friendships being made and lost and it
was like that was all we talked about it
at school I don't want to brag but so
sometime around this is gotta be around
87 or so zelda 2 came out Adventure of
Link and I was at my grandma's in Jersey
and I think the store was called Caldor
it's just like you're just like a Sears
kind of
door and I remember I knew when when
Zelda 2 was supposed to come out it
wasn't supposed to come out for like a
couple weeks or something and they had a
copy of it there and I begged and begged
and begged pleaded with my grandma
please please please my grandma buys us
in this game which was probably like 50
bucks which was a lot of money at the
time you know and my brother and I beat
it in about two weeks now it's thought
of I think is one of the most complex
yeah it's really one of the most
difficult Elda games out there but we
took a picture of ourselves as we beat
it a black-and-white picture that
appeared in Nintendo Power magazine
really all right back identity I could
end this show right now that's it that's
so cool yeah so alright so Nintendo
really changes the game with this and
then at the same time now Sega comes out
with the Master System right I truly
don't remember anyone that I know that
had the Master System it was like a joke
to us yeah I mean that's not unusual
like this wasn't like a Coke Pepsi
situation where coke had like 65% the
market like Nintendo actually had over
95% of the market one of my favorite ads
from that time was it was an attitude
from Ariane since there's no such thing
as a Nintendo because that's my mom
still calls every video game a Nintendo
but I never worry about the trademark
concerns of like you know the way
Jacuzzi has come to represent hot tub
for Kleenex yeah so like Nintendo was at
the point where they were so synonymous
with video games that it was actually a
synonym for video games and so they were
so dominant and then Sega essentially
realized that they couldn't win this
8-bit battle so they tried to change the
location on the war to 16-bits you know
twice as good graphics but as we sort of
touched on earlier you know death
doesn't make it more fun necessarily it
makes it flat here and and a lot of
people think that the genesis came in
and started to eat into Nintendo's
market sure but that's not actually
happened the genesis launched in the
United States in 1989 and it struggled
the two big changes were the arrival of
a guy named Sonic the Hedgehog the
middle name is actually the capital T
yeah and then this guy tom kalinske who
became the president and CEO of sega of
america in 1990 and led them from you
know less than 5% over 55% and he's the
central protagonist of my story and and
you know
he's so important to point out because I
basically realized as I written these
interviews with him but other than my
parents he is the adult most responsible
for my child ha laughs back to the 60s
yet his first job advertising agency
Jane Walter Thompson he helped create
the Flintstones chewable vitamins and
then he went to Mattel when their think
about retiring the Barbie line and
helped revive Barbie and then did for
boys but Barbie did for girls with
he-man Master the universe oh he's just
this guy who had this golden touch
everywhere he went and oh you know I
just I just watched that show on Netflix
that I'm sure you've so NASA it's the
history of yeah well it's like the
history of toys I forgot it's called the
toys we loved or something like that and
they talked about him in the in the heat
right now
he said he's amazing you know usually
would I you're doing these interviews
over years you see different sides of
people hold on like he really is just an
incredible role model he does things the
right way and it's not shocking that he
seems to have this magic touch because
everyone has such nice things to say and
you know so it took say get out of the
gutter you know sort of famously one of
the big narrative turning points was he
delivered this four-point plan to Japan
and so it's important to note that Sega
is a Japanese company even though it's
founded by an American and then Tom was
in charge of the American division and
as is someone else with the case today
like the American sector is the biggest
sector so but it was a weird situation
where America's subsidiary in Japan is
the parent company and Tom proposed four
things among them was competitive
head-to-head advertising against
Nintendo which was frowned upon in Japan
bundling bundling Sega's best game with
the Genesis relaunch which turned out to
be Sonic the Hedgehog and then the
Japanese we remember stuff that was
crazy because you know that's how you
make your money it's a razor and razor
blades business we're just giving up
this $50 so that was a little bit after
Sega had debuted though cuz Sonic wasn't
on the original yes I didn't come out
until 1991 so it was almost like a
relaunch under Tom and that's when they
started to really carve into Nintendo's
space and also do more sports games
because you know Japan didn't really
care that much about American baseball
or football and doing all these things
that worked and and and then you know a
year later Nintendo launched the Super
Nintendo and I returned the way I got
into writing the book was I remembered
as a kid I had the NES it was the
greatest thing in the world
and so naturally when I heard the Super
Nintendo my brother and I wanted that
and we put together like the childhood
equivalent of a PowerPoint presentation
with you know two birthdays a Hanukkah
fourth of July whatever like we need to
get this and I remember my dad saying no
he wouldn't buy us the superintend my
dad's awesome he'd always you know try
to figure out a way you say about this
but he had no interest in getting us a
Super Nintendo because it was not
backwardly compatible and people parents
felt hi yeah yeah library and I won't
work even though you know you could just
tie all the cords but back then the
whole behind his house did they have a
splitter back then yeah if I remember
doing that too we there was one audio a
video out basically or in and I would
have Genesis and Nintendo and you're
like a precocious young you can only
have one system yeah but so my parents
wouldn't get that for us and we ended up
getting a Genesis and I became a Sega
kid and and it's just interesting and
sort of the context of how around spoke
because I like behind-the-scenes
business stories and looking back
because of a decision at the board room
somewhere we're like no we don't want to
make it back early compatible because I
would end $35 the system my life changed
and I became a same ken and then on the
school year and I was fighting for team
saying yeah yeah and these were fights I
mean I remember having fights in the in
lunchroom probably now I've got to be in
eighth grade yeah fighting with kids
over my friend Ari
he had like Super Nintendo that bum but
I liked it was like civil like I
remember it like he did but like still
friendly we all played games at the end
of the day but like we would be
screaming at each other and you know
yelling and know what what games did you
like on Sega Genesis I was always into
the sports game I was the only you know
I feel like I'm very good at it NHL 94
which is that my favorite game of all
time it's in there did you see it no I
did it's in there that's amazing yeah so
yeah I like the sports games ma jam and
I also really love because there's you
know not all games for two players who
sport games really were and I had this
brother or have this brother who's two
years younger than me and now he's my
best friend but back then I hated him I
despised and he was so nice and I was so
nice and and and that was like you know
playing genesis and Nintendo I was like
the one thing that we did
like friends yeah that was a lot of my
good memories it's interesting that I
can see that a good portion of this that
excites you is the is the business part
and the and the marketing part because I
remembered seeing Sega Genesis for the
first time my friend Josh had and I went
to his house and he was playing ghouls
and ghosts which i think was in that
original they came out with maybe six or
eight games altered beast I think came
with the systems and then but I remember
seeing ghouls and ghosts and my mind was
blown like it was the graphics were so
much better the colors were so much
richer the music was incredible it
really was like arcade quality which you
mentioned like that was kind of where we
first saw a lot of his games and it was
a big step up yeah but you're saying
that actually didn't have that much to
do necessarily with the success that it
really was more on the marketing and the
business anything or do you think that
it was so such an obvious jump well I
would just say that the genesis came out
in 1989 exactly described with altered
beast and ghouls and goblins and all
that stuff and it didn't do well so it
clearly had to be more than just the
games and you know I think a good story
that sort of sums up what this was all
like and sort of the spirit Sega and why
I was fascinated writing about it was
you know as kids and even as adults you
sort of imagined there's this
meritocracy to it like the best consoles
won't have most shelf space and sell the
most amount but that wasn't the case
yeah especially because Nintendo had you
know monopolistic practices they later
faced the FTC issues so I'm not really
speaking out of school to say that we're
you know every situation where they
counted for such a great deal of like
Walmart I think they counted for 10
percent of Walmart's business one year
Wow just this one
you know division of the you know this
20 by 20 space in the store and so you
know if Walmart wants to carry another
console Nintendo would say oh well then
you know maybe the Mario Brothers three
shipments gonna not make it to you guys
that we can't control what happens with
these and so they did a lot of stuff
like that and so you know I remember
hearing stories from people say guy that
they'd go to Walmart and be like here's
our new console it's better kids like
Dave Ruel say like you know look at
these graphics is better and Walmart's
like yeah but like sorry we're not we
have a relationship with Nintendo and so
what's Sega ended up doing was a crop
they you know they were down in
Bentonville Arkansas that was the heart
quarters of Walmart and across the
street from the headquarters was this
small area and there was a ferment sign
so they rented this area and they opened
the Sega Genesis store which sold
nothing but it just encourage people to
come in and play this play the Genesis
for free huh and they also bought every
billboard and that build they bought the
seat cushions of the football games they
turn Sega
they basically turned been known to say
evil and then you had all these people
going into the flagship Walmart store
being like where can I get a Sega
Genesis and you know that's like clever
cheap guerilla marketing and that is
what eventually got the Walmart VP to
call up tom kalinske and say alright we
raise the red flag we're gonna carry a
secret product so you know you know I
don't want to dismiss the importance of
the games themselves like none of this
would exist without the games themselves
and like if you were starting a game
company that probably not more thing I
tell you to focus on but it's not enough
as with a lot of things you know good
content if you have to figure out a way
to get it to people and especially when
you're dealing with a competitor like
Nintendo is it mind-blowing for someone
like you that knows the history of it
and also played them to see what the
videogame world has become now that it
has become it's not just you know I'm
probably know the numbers on how much
revenue games are bringing in and all
that stuff but it's not just about the
numbers and the finances that it's
become a culture unto itself I think
there's a direct connection between the
culture war that we're fighting
politically and having a lot to do with
the video game world and gamer getting
all these things that that it the video
game culture birthed out some other
thing no it's so amazing that you know
like I said I'm not very good at video
games and I don't really play much games
nowadays and so if with most things like
that where I'm not good at or I feel
like you know the young kids are using
snapchat I don't care like I kind of
feel like a crotchety old man
yeah with games I almost feel like I'm
smiling off the side proud like I love
the kids get it in a way that I don't
even though it makes me feel like I'm
missing something
I just cuz I love gaming I love the
culture around it and I never would have
expected this to happen like I remember
like I said my father was awesome so he
would play Mary Rose one with my brother
and I but he did it in the same way as
like a parent would go to a tea party
with it with a child like it was like he
was nothing kind of standing but it was
this is a kid thing that I'm doing and
and and I'd say you know I think that
the most important part of their legacy
is how they transform what video games
were from childish playthings into
consumer electronics they're obviously
not around in the same way anymore but
that is really like the answer to why
does this time period matter and the
other thing
so let's await let's say like that for a
second so okay so there's there's the
NES and then Sega Genesis comes in but
what is that transition that you're
talking about where they got into
consumer that culture so so basically
you know when tom kalinske took over he
realized they tend to say that 95% the
market and they were just so dominant
with kids 6 to 14 that to use their you
know it was its kind it was kinda like a
Moneyball story where they had like 1/10
the resources of Nintendo so to try to
get Nintendo's core dance didn't work
and so they've figured all right well
zag so you know you guys can have the
kids we're gonna go after teenagers and
adults which you know like my dad like
that was just not the audience and so
say good instead of selling KB Toys
wanted to get into you know the back
then version of Best Buy basically
entity into places where you buy a cool
Sony Walkman it's not that interesting
and and then they also just shame you
know like the marketing right it was a
big deal like what you described with
zelda ii was not uncommon there was not
really release dates of these things
like even though you knew it was coming
in a few weeks like the fact that they
were you selling it ahead of time it
wouldn't come back the same day in the
same places and sega followed but you
know they wanted to make a model like
them like the film industry it's like to
make a big deal out of like this is
coming here's a trailer for it here's
all these months of hype for better or
for worse but that is what gave us sort
of the modern game industry and the
culture around it I'm just gonna say
that you know one of the things that was
amazing to me was you know I put you
this book proposal for console wars and
at that time Seth Rogen had already
optioned it to do a movie he was gonna
produce a documentary for me and my
buddy Jonah tooless to direct it Scott
Rudin was involved that he had adapted
you know some of my favorite books and
the movies like The Accidental
billionaires social network so like this
dream-team package in which I'm like
deport in person but I was so happy and
I thought like this should be a slam
dunk of course we're gonna sell this is
sathru and it's got rooted and Sega
Nintendo and and the proposal want the
25 publishers and 22 of them passed
because I said video game books don't
sell they said gamers don't read and so
that's why part of the reason I just
feel such a kinship with the gaming
audience one because they bought the
book it proved the publisher wrong and
two because their their talk down to all
the time they're they're underestimated
all the time and it's ridiculous
had ready player one not already wrong
well you know I think ready player one
had come out in 2012 right so it had
come out but they would say oh that's it
on you know my books on fiction that's a
fiction sci-fi book mm-hmm even though
it's clearly taps in that same audience
but I'm sure wouldn't shock you to know
that most publishers have a sort of
older school business model that maybe
could use some updating as I'm in the
midst of writing my first book at the
moment I've become keenly aware of this
yeah okay so so now Sega starts winning
basically now Super Nintendo comes out
the competitions again what I someone
told me actually but am I getting this
right the Super Nintendo actually
outsell Sega at some point yeah so we go
from because that seems hard for me to
believe too because you're talking about
we all cordoned off in our own little
world I was in a Genesis world so most
of my friends had Genesis so it's hard
for me to believe that that could be
true well to us ya know was okay so in
1989 Sega strikes out with Genesis 1990
some leeway some some headway 1991 they
come out Sonic Tom's plans are executed
and they still you know Nintendo's
Nintendo so Nintendo still out sells
them at first and then slowly but surely
Sega keeps gaining momentum and then the
big turning point was Mortal Kombat you
know this was a game that so back then
like arcade games are almost like the
minor leagues of these consoles I kind
of never go in a pizza possess our local
pizza place and like they had more
comment was a huge deal yeah this is
coming to the consoles and and usually
what would happen is one of the two
console makers
Daigo would get the exclusive rights to
it and it would come to that system like
Street Fighter 2 Street Fighter over -
at least initially was only available in
the Super Nintendo
that really helps Herbert and I really
hope they tend that was a third-party
game and then they had first party games
like Mario Kart and Zelda and all that
and and and acclaim the makers of Mortal
Kombat decided that they wanted to
release on both systems on the same day
which was not only interesting but it
was also just like a great litmus test
between Sega Nintendo like for once it
just and that was against Nintendo's
policies at the time right didn't they
get into some fight with Tekken I think
about that because they were trying to
release things on differences yeah it
was involved with all sorts of
strong-arm tactics some of them that
ended up leading the core cases like the
antitrust stuff and you know also
famously they sued Galoob the makers of
game genie because they probably had
like you know this was messing up their
creative games by giving you extra lives
they also sued blockbuster and and the
rental companies because they said you
know you can't rent out our games
attended end up winning a lot of these
things but but that was also good
because like like you noticed like I
love the behind the scenes stuff that
that's where I think the drama is and
that's another big reason that Sega was
successful because these are gloob is a
name and it's a company but it's also
people so Sega decided that they're
gonna form a cartel Nintendo's enemies
and be like Nintendo's really strict
with you guys we won't work with you
let's make this happen and there's
people at Kalu were like yes let's go
out of our way to actually be Nintendo
so you you know whether it's
partnerships like that or whether
there's just small things I remember
talking to the buyer at the Wiz and he
said you know we couldn't explicitly do
anything really early on but like he
would always make sure that the genesis
had the prime real estate even though it
was a small space he was like that's the
one that would face the consumer because
they they just they all wanted to see a
Nintendo fall and then Mortal Kombat
comes along and Mortal Kombat was a
fighting game that was famous for its
violence and gore specifically the
fatalities reactive someone spying out
which now is like hilariously comical
yeah back then like it was a big deal
obviously that was one us kids liked
about it to a degree and a Nintendo went
to acclaim and said because of their
family friendly image that Nintendo had
they said can you make can you we want
you to tone down the violence and change
the blood
from red to like grayish green and the
guy who claimed was like all right well
that's pi not gonna work
meanwhile I'll say it was like alright
we can amp up the violence they had a
version that was a little more tame but
you enter the blood code you know the
cult of kids that play this game all new
right away and and that was a big
turning point because the sega version
outsold when tendo version like five to
one and it also you know what I always
thought this is like a funny aside was
Howard Lincoln the senior vice president
endo said they knew that they were going
to lose business but they thought it was
important to stick to that core values
but he thought and so he thought like
well at least we'd get a lot of parents
and we thank you blessed you Nintendo
for doing the right thing but instead
they got a lot of angry letters for
censorship you said to the games so yeah
but they were also under pressure I mean
there were politicians at the time that
were saying these games were too violent
that's an interesting thing because
Nintendo had generally squeaky-clean
games they really are like the Disney
the Pixar of gaming and they've stayed
that way I think partly because Sega
kind of put but you know show them that
they can't go beyond you know Nintendo
took advantage of that niche but
Nintendo felt like Sega was doing
inappropriate things you know what I
came to realize is that it was just you
know there was not necessarily good guy
or bad guy was just ideological
differences whereas Nintendo is very
much like Apple closed system they want
to control every aspect of of the the
chain and while you know that's sort of
totalitarian it also leads to a really
high consumer experience and then
tenseiga was all about choice so if
you're a developer and you want to make
a game with some adult themes go for it
whereas in tendo say Halleck you know i
think of the children i didn't say go as
i know think of the developers like or
children don't have to buy it so
Nintendo made sort of the greatest hits
VHS tape of Sega's about the violence on
Sega system and started slipping that to
people in Washington so there were lots
in gaming since 73 like I said early
Behrman yeah
but they didn't have my accident you
know a Nintendo was pretty psyched to
make this happen
and so yes I love that behind-the-scenes
drama and I want my favorite things was
you know when I when I first started
writing this I imagined like oh this is
like a great rivalry like like like
Larry
Magic Johnson like it's two great
competitors who who fight on the court
but like you know they respect each
other they push each other green levers
levels and you know it's been 20 years
or 25 years since this and I think every
single person I interviewed from
Nintendo still hates everyone at Sega he
thinks they're a bunch of frauds and
marketing hucksters and everyone at Sega
hates people antenna style I think
they're a bunch of bullies and they're
both right yeah well that's what it's
all about that's what the competition is
all about it so it's interesting though
because if you think about it at some
level in terms of keeping the core
values of were more of a disney company
we don't go violent maybe we focus a
little more on fun instead of hardcore
graphics or whatever Nintendo has kept
that in that core image right even even
to now right behind the scenes they were
doing all sorts of shady stuff and just
you know we're dealing with politicians
and you know and that was like a really
big deal remember
these were like adults running the
companies like they they like they think
we're all kind of cool yeah but it but
it's against the image of the company
and again these are also Japanese owned
companies so you know the large part of
the reason that my book focuses so much
on Sega is is because that's where the
action is that's the David versus
Goliath story but it's also they had a
lot of autonomy Nintendo was a lot more
carrying out orders from Japan and Japan
didn't want to get more into adult
content like one idea that I think
actually would have worked was I'm gonna
botch this but like you know Disney had
subsidiary production nobody's like was
at Castle Rock like basically stuff that
did it all content that was made and
financed by Disney but it didn't feel
Disney cuz it had a different name and I
think the Nintendo it would have served
them well to sort of be doing it
different sorts of content but trying to
distance themselves from right but they
but they couldn't give the green light
to do those things and I think that you
know Nintendo's philosophy has always
been very like slow and steady wins the
race you know that saying it did surpass
them but then say yes sort of busted in
94 and for several years and 10 don't
continue to sell SNES games well what
caused that bust with Sega Genesis oh
few things I think one of things I found
really fascinating but the console wars
is that unlike actual worse which are
much more serious of course but like wow
like there's a whether you win or lose
some
has changed and you're in a position of
strength or weakness going forward in
the council Wars you can kick ass one
generation and then that doesn't
necessarily help you in any way when you
learn the next generation so it's like
every five years it's a reset and so
that next generation console is such a
big deal and and and it's a writer I
couldn't have asked for like a more
poetic ending than the fact that you
know what happened was Sega of America
was so successful and you know we talked
about this battle between Sega Nintendo
that didn't happen in Japan did Japan
Sega never surpassed like 15 percent and
that's that was a weird dynamic where
the people who were actually making most
of the games
we're not succeeding and part of it I
would say is because they didn't have
the risk appetite to go head-to-head to
do all these things that say you know of
America was doing and I remember you
couldn't use the Mega Drive cartridges
in a separate analysis because they
design them slightly differently because
they just want to do things in their way
and the American Way seemed to be
working
but while Sega was like Sega of America
was hitting its stride and saying of
Japan's like alright let's let's go into
the next console and and there's you
know making some merit at they were
always working the next consoles but
they came up with something to became
the Sega Saturn which whether or not
like whether or not you think the
technical specs were great or not it was
very hard for developers to create
content for which is a real problem
because exactly they're really your main
customer so tom kalinske
wanted to console that we thought would
do a lot better he he initially
approached Sony who was working on a
console of their own they were
presenting a joint partnership to sony
Sony was team on board saying rejected
it that became the Sony PlayStation that
so that basically could have been the
Sega place they exactly Wow and then and
then a similar thing happened with
Silicon Graphics the chip makers they
contacted Tom and showed their new
system shown what could be the base
foundation of a new system times like
this is great this is cheaper and then
they got rejected by Sega of Japan and
that ended up not you know leading to
new n64 so basically Sega had the chance
to actually have put out the two
competitors that destroyed it Wow which
is interesting yeah you know going
writing a fine
Paige book I remember that my grandma
can't do I so it's about Dan Brown desk
read but ready for the between say
intend oh I assume that the most
important battle would be between
Nintendo and Sega but it actually was
between Sega of America and Sega Japan
there was a sort of a civil war that
that doomed the company a lot of it was
based on jealousy the most simplest way
to put it but but like either I could be
sympathetic to if you're actually making
the games and you're not really getting
the credit because you're not you know
you're not actually selling systems so
it's just a really interesting dynamic
and then I ended up actually being hired
by Sega of America to shoot some
documentaries for Sega of Japan and this
was 15 20 years later so you know the
caveat that can't it's not the same
people you got say but I totally
experience everything that people felt
like like for example we brought all
this film equipment and every set up
took like an hour and we asked for just
one room to do the interview said they
made a switch rooms for everybody they
did every little to make good to
undermine us to try to make the
experience worse and it was like dudes
we're making videos that's gonna help
sell your games were supposed to the
same team here so I felt like I
experienced a little bit of what sake of
America experience then and it said but
fortunately like you know I the other
day I was on the subway I live in New
York and I saw a kid like a 8 year old
kid wearing a t-shirt of Sonic the
Hedgehog well there hasn't been a good
sign of Hedgehog game in the past year
so the reason the faculty is wearing it
is because Sega of America did such a
great job of creating that character
that you know I always think of this
idea of like what's in a name you know
that Mario's last name is what Mario
like he doesn't have that he was just
originally jump man and then he became
Mario we're gonna Sonic I see you gonna
thaw all these things out there was
Sonic the Hedgehog isn't middle name is
afterthought there was a whole Bible and
backstory and like they did all the
stuff that's a storyteller I love like
they felt like these characters are real
and I think that's that's why it's
successful you know there's it's not you
people almost take for granted the fact
that Sonic is so successful where is if
you think of other mascot characters
like pac-man or Frogger Crash Bandicoot
like but we still have fond memories of
them and they'll pop up from time to
time but like they're not a global icon
like Sonic isn't yeah it reminds me of
in that same Netflix show that I wish I
could remember what it was called the
toys that made the toys that made it
yeah
where they talk about that the GI Joe
was being sort of rebooted into our 80s
GI Joe and big ones yeah from the big
ones down to the ones that we played
with like this but basically
transformers was so hot I think in 1984
that they shelved it for a year but then
what they did do in that year while they
were waiting was they had the guy go in
and write the backstory so all the stuff
that was on the back of the cartridges
so all the things that you're describing
Sega was able to do GI Joe basically had
a year to come up with it and that ended
up sort of flourishing and in so many
other ways and then cartoons and
everything else okay do we have anything
else to say about consoles before we
move to the current year we should just
say I could do 10 Joseph I you know I
basically feel like the last eight years
of my life I spent three three years on
console wars and four years on this new
book and and at that point of my life
it's 2014 my book is being made into
movie and now it's gonna be a TV show
with all these people who I grew up
loving their movies my book is a
best-seller it's sold it's it's by far
some of the most books of all time in
the video game category which we should
remember is like a very small category
come on come on out but you know things
are good and and then I ended up working
on this book about oculus and as well
get into like this experience was so
different because of the political
aspect and how it weaved into this areas
that I never expected and and why I
found listen to show is such a comfort
you
[Music]